[Musique]
nouvelle édition du 7 8 politique
municipale 2020 sur terré 60,18 merci de
nous rejoindre je reçois aujourd'hui
grégory pape bonsoir consignes venues en
plateau candidats à guyancourt votre
liste nouvel élan à guyancourt vous avez
reçu l'investiture et les rues m en
marche on a d'ailleurs vu didier
baichère le député de la première
circonscription qui couvre guyancourt
présent lors de votre lancement de
campagne aujourd'hui est ce que votre
liste est clairement celle du parti
présidentiel
oui j'ai effectivement reçu
l'investiture de m
ce qui est un honneur pour moi parce que
je suis en marche depuis depuis le début
je je suis totalement en phase avec les
valeurs dans marche qui sont d'une
gauche ni droite pas de sectarisme ni
dogmatisme et j'insiste bien sur le fait
que c'est la tête de liste c'est à dire
moi même grégory pape qui suit l hérault
m
vous êtes lru m sur votre liste
différentes sensibilités will personnes
sans étiquette du mandat social
exactement rose un peu votre lice
aujourd'hui
excusez moi qui composent cette liste
aujourd'hui justement aujourd'hui au
niveau politique
oui au niveau politique ça valait
vraiment la gauche jusqu'à la droite
j'ai également le soutien modem donc
vous lisiez en tout à l'heure vous êtes
landes est l'un des premiers marcheurs
sur cette commune de guyancourt
marcheurs de la première heure vous avez
vous êtes responsables de ce comité
local rlr même circuit en cours pourquoi
avoir rejoint ce parti présidentiel dès
le début qu'est ce qui vous a motivé
dans la démarche
c'est votre première campagne politique
c'est la première campagne politique je
suis neuf en politique et avant je ne
m'intéressais pas la politique parce que
je ne me reconnaissais pas dans les
débat gauche droite quand la gauche
proposait une idée un projet la droite
est systématiquement ça ne va pas c'est
la gauche qui l'a proposé et inversement
avec en marche on ne parle que de
projets et c'est ça qui m'intéresse
c'est ce qui vous a motivé à rejoindre
le nrm dès le début puis en course est
un bastion de la gauche depuis la fin de
la seconde guerre mondiale un du pcf
ensuite au parti socialiste en 83 avec
l'élection de roland nadeau savoir
vous pensez ce bastion prenable
justement ce bastion de la gauche
aujourd'hui est prenable
alors oui vous savez là l'équipe
actuelle de l'huile en cour municipale a
vécu un mandat très difficile nous avons
eu trois maires sur ce mandat
trois intérimaires et l'équipe actuelle
semble vraiment à court de ressources
alors je reprécise françois de ligne et
qui a été élu lors du dernier scrutin en
2014 a passé la main on le voit sur ces
images il a passé la main en cours de
route à marie-christine le tarnais qui
elle a dû démissionner pour raisons de
santé ensuite au profit de françois
morton qui a été élu et qui est donc lui
candidat également et qui sera votre
adversaire dans cette campagne des
municipales qu'elle reproche vous faites
sur le sur les projets sur le fond à
cette équipe sortante au delà du fait
que les trois maires successifs qui est
assez inédit sur une commune mais sur le
fond sur le projet sur les actions qui
ont été menées que reprochez vous à
cette équipe et ensuite on parlera de
votre projet plus en détail bien sûr
alors lui en cours c'est un beau navire
mais en navire qui met la barre du même
côté pendant 37 ans finit par tourner en
rond je trouve que cette équipe n'a plus
le dynamisme nécessaire pour la ville
ensuite l'équipe municipale donne
l'impression d'être en rupture avec le
choeur décisionnel de saint quentin en
yvelines
nous souhaitons vraiment remettre vie en
cours dans sucker décisionnel car
l'agglomération est très importante vos
quotidiens l'agglomération gère la
voirie j'avais lampadaires les habitants
ne se rendent pas compte mais c'est
vraiment l'agglomération qui a laissé
des légalisations là donc c'est très
important
vraiment très important que guyancourt
de renouer le lien avec l'agglomération
aujourd'hui le lien et ont fait entre
saint quentin en yvelines
l'agglomération et lui en cours oui ça
me paraît quand les questions politiques
de part des choix qui j'ai l'impression
que monsieur morton défend ses valeurs
de gauche et monsieur focus défense des
valeurs de droite et du coup ça ça
communique moins bien peut-être une
précision aussi non pas sur votre liste
mais sur votre comité de soutien sont
responsables et l'ancien président de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines robert
cadalbert est le même
socialistes et qui a fait partie des
anciennes équipes qui ont dirigé la
ville de guyancourt exactement mais
comme dit souvent robert cadalbert il
faisait dur en marche sans s'en rendre
compte du sol le projet l'intéressait je
vais vous présenter un petit peu plus
vous avez 40 en pharmacie ans père de
trois enfants
c'est un combat difficile une campagne
politique
pourquoi vous engagez dans cette
démarche et ne pas rester sans votre
coeur de votre métier premier
vous savez je vis à vis en cours depuis
quelques années et si tout allait bien
je m'appliquerai jamais autant dans ce
projet de ville pour moi c'est un
challenge st challenge personnel parce
que j'ai déjà plusieurs activités
c'est un challenge pour ma ville parce
que je veux la remettre à la hauteur de
ses ambitions
c'est un challenge car je veux renouer
le contact avec la jeunesse à guyancourt
parmi vos projets atelier budget
participatif on retrouve des choses
qu'on voit régulièrement dans les
projets en marche un atelier budget
participatif conseil de quartier de vie
associative comité d'évaluation des
projets par les habitants et quelles
sont les mesures phares que vous allez
dégagez pendant cette campagne
comme je vous comme je vous l'avais déjà
dit on va renouer le contact avec saint
quentin en yvelines
nous avons déjà communiqué une partie de
notre programme sur le mode de
gouvernance actuellement légumes
courtois ce ne sont que très peu
consulté la démocratie participative
c'est faire participer les citoyens aux
décisions de leur ville ce que nous
souhaitons c'est remettre un conseil un
conseil dans chaque quartier et ses
conseils auront un budget participatif
ça nous sommes les premiers à proposer
ensuite nous souhaitons constituer un
conseil de vie associative qui va
permettre de mutualiser les besoins
entre les associations
un conseil de la jeunesse pour comme je
voulais dire renouer le contact avec la
jeunesse et enfin vous pouvez le voir
sur les affiches actuellement dans le
deuil en cours le fameux engagements
pris engagements tenus par la
municipalité actuelle mais ce qui me
gêne c'est que
sur 7 sur ce slogan c'est la mairie elle
même qui est juge et partie
si nous sommes élus nous mettrons en
place un comité d'évaluation neutre et
objectif il ya des dossiers importants
qui vont concerner cette commune de
guyancourt on aura le temps d'y revenir
pendant la campagne mais il ya cet
aménagement de la commune
aussi dans le cadre du de la ligne 18
qui doit donc arriver sur guyancourt
vous avez un projet une des
déménagements une réflexion sur cette
arrivée de la ligne 18 dans les
prochaines années oui nous sommes
conscients que nous ne serons pas
décisionnaire au final mais ce que nous
allons proposer c'est de mettre un tc hp
entre saclay et la gare de saint-quentin
en attendant que cette ligne 18 soit
faite parce qu'on a aucun détail sur le
dellec transport en site propre c'est
précisément pour pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas les différences d'un
gros nîmes donc ligne 18 aménagements à
arriver de ce super métro de passage sur
saint quentin en yvelines l'insécurité
aussi d'aussi important pour vous vous
avez le sentiment que c'est ce que vous
dites en tout cas dans ce qu'on peut
lire jusqu'à présent dans vos
différentes déclarations vous dites il
ya plus d'incivilités dans cette commune
aujourd'hui non c'est ce que j'ai
remarqué depuis je suis arrivé dans
cette ville
j'ai récemment rencontré une personne
âgée qui s'est fait renverser par les
mini motos au printemps dernier vous
avez dû couvrir l'événement j'imagine je
passe était vraiment important j'ai vu
son témoignage qui était poignant et il
est vraiment temps de prendre ce
problème à bras le corps et donc ça veut
dire quoi plus de policiers municipaux
alors déjà ça veut dire plus de
prévention plus de prévention et
comprendre ce qu'il se passe et ensuite
effectivement plus de moyens sur la
police municipale j'en reviens puisque
nous arrivons à presque à terme au terme
de cet entretien sur votre gouvernance
avec saint quentin en yvelines vous
dites vouloir renouer le lien si vous
êtes élu vous aller échanger discuter
faire des alliances avec les différentes
tendances tout dépendra des résultats
des autres villes mais aujourd'hui et si
les choses restaient en l'état vous
allez discuter avec une majorité divers
droite et l'ère républicaine
donc je suis neuf en politique mais du
coup je suis ni cynique ni blasé
donc je suis prêt à discuter avec tout
le monde à condition qu'on soit d'accord
sur le projet est ce que vous avez
changé avec les autres listes aussi
également elles sont nombreuses déjà
présente sur cette commune de guyancourt
françois mortes ont donc lancé le maire
qui se représentent
olivier paréja qui faisait partie de la
première majorité en 2014 qui s'en est
éloigné ensuite qui se pressent
et puis le sans étiquette rodolphe barry
vous avez déjà échanges et les contacts
sont assez distant pour l'instant
personne n'a encore sorti son programme
donc nous nous contacterons sûrement une
fois que les programmes second tour qui
seront diffusés que vous aurez
l'occasion d'échanger sur ce plateau
avec les différentes listes puisque nous
organiserons des débats vous le savez
sur notre antenne de tv 78 dans les
différentes communes
un mot également sur une nouvelle liste
qui s'est fait connaître cette semaine
c'est l'union des démocrates musulmans
français et qui a fait savoir qu'il aura
un candidat ma belle à des qte plusieurs
figures de droite ont réclamé
l'interdiction de listes communautariste
aux élections municipales alors lui dmf
donc répond qu'elle n'est pas et ne sera
jamais un parti confessionnel ni réservé
aux musulmans
né au mans vous avez un regard sur cette
liste noël à se monter nous prenons la
laïcité évidemment pour moi nous ne vont
pas mettre en avant notre appartenance
religieuse sur votre campagne pour
terminer prochain rendez vous qui sont
prévues prochain rendez vous donc nous
allons renouer le contact à la jeunesse
parce qu'il ya un souci d'abstention sur
ce secteur d'âge à guyancourt
donc nous allons lancer les caravanes
citoyenne dès jeudi soir nous serons
pondu route war à 18 heures car ce n'est
pas aux jeunes de venir re de venir vers
nous c'est nous qui allons les voir
parce que pour redonner confiance en la
politique
merci grégory pape candidats induit en
cours vise nouvel élan à lui encore
merci le 7-8 politique se poursuit
cette édition de 7,8 politique
municipale 2020 dont qui se poursuit sur
terré 78 de chaque mardi en direct vous
le savez à 18h45 nous faisons le point
sur les différentes communes des
yvelines avant le premier tour ce sera
le 15 mars direction versailles à
présent où le maire divers droite
françois de mazières veut mettre un
terme aux rumeurs je n'ai sollicité
d'investiture est ni de soutien ni de
parti ni mener une quelconque
négociation sur la composition de la
future liste c'est ce qu'il a écrit dans
un communiqué adressé aux différentes
rédactions aux médias locaux une réponse
à la main tendue par le député issu du
parti présidentiel didier baichère la
semaine précédente
françois de mazières dévoilera dans les
prochaines semaines les noms de ses
colistiers qui devrait être de
sensibilité de centre droit et de droite
en cohérence avec ses choix depuis
maintenant 11 ans on notera tout de même
qu'il a d'ores et déjà annoncé que ni
françois xavier bellamy chez maintenant
élus européens annie martin est lévriers
maintenant est ce sénateur lrm
repartirait en campagne avec lui
mantes-la-ville à présent cyril aux
seuls élus franciliens du rassemblement
national annonce lui que quatre de ses
cinq adjoints actuels repartent en
campagne avec lui là pour le reste de la
liste il appelle en revanche les
habitants à le rejoindre dans une lettre
ouverte à condition dit-il d'adhérer à
son bilan son projet il ne sera pas
nécessaire précise-t-il d'adhérer au
mouvement de marine le pen autres
communes rambouillet david jutier tête
de liste à un rambouillet a dévoilé ses
premiers axes de programmes l'actuel
élus d'opposition europe ecologie les
verts au sein du conseil municipal
entend revoir le plan de circulation est
de développer un centre municipal de
santé ou encore instaurer un moratoire
sur les terres agricoles et les espaces
naturels et pour terminer nous passons
aux agendas avec deux dates à vous
communiquer maurepas à tout d'abord où
la liste divers gauche mené par l'ancien
conseiller départemental socialiste is
my la vanne lancera sa campagne ce sera
le 9 décembre à 20 heures à la maison du
voisinage des coudrais et puis à la
verrière le conseiller départemental
l'est républicain nicolas d'un ville
organisera le 12 décembre une réunion
publique avec le maire de poissy
également conseiller départemental
fondateur du mouvement générations
terrain karl olive
ce sera aux scarabées et nicolas
mainville qui sera
le prochain invité du 7-8 politique
mardi 10 décembre dès 18h45 la campagne
des municipales est à suivre également
sur notre site internet vous retrouverez
tous nos reportages nos entretiens
également et puis les agendas des
candidats très belle semaine et à
bientôt
[Musique]